Now, you've got the skills to start
documenting your code with simply
readmes written in Markdown.
If and when your code grows,
you may want to
explore other forms of documentation,
but this is a great place to start.
Writing great code isn't just about
building something that works,
but building something that's both
easy to use and easy to maintain.
If you're documenting your code,
then you're writing code that's
meant to be used by humans.
Being conscious of this fact beforehand
will make you a better developer.
I'm going to leave you with a challenge.
Go revisit some of the projects you've
built and write a readme for them.
Make documentation a priority for
all your projects moving forward.
You'll thank yourself later.